[Music]
what's going on guys
this week's honest trailer has been lost
in the space-time continuum but you may
be seeing it in the pretty near future
in the meantime huge news something
caused millions of nerds to sit through
football last night the force awakens
trailer we got a couple of cool dudes to
talk about it with break it down first
he's a producer at screen junkies and
you know him as the pit boss from
schmoes no 10 abs ah Ken welcome to the
party pal it'll happen to be a what a
great time to be a Star Wars fan I'm so
glad we're awake to celebrate a great
time to be alive right and uh you know
him you'll love them it's Dan Merle I'm
still here guys
the force awakens trailer this head
amateur feel to it there's death there's
destruction in every teaser trailer now
this full-length a stormtrooper body has
gone flying but there's gonna be fun
you've seen we've seen bb-8 there have
always been fun moments but what I love
is the fact that I'm now watched three
trailers for this and yet I still don't
know anything about it I don't know what
the plots about I love that III don't
know what to expect from this movie they
haven't made a misstep I agree you can
start putting stuff together with
context and hey that character shows up
there this is happening there but
they've also done in such a way where I
think we've only seen parts of the movie
yeah we didn't get a good clear look at
Luke Skywalker hashtag where's Luke you
got on the poster now he's not in the
trailer we know he's in the movie or
some say that maybe him in the trailer
like a hand to r2d2 I am of the school
that that is not Luke Skywalker on red
herring it could end up being I could
lose that bet yeah it'd be fun to think
that no were still not seeing him at all
I want that revealed to be very special
I'm glad we haven't seen it yet
the speculation from the last one was
that Darth Vader mask yeah people were
speculating maybe that's just a shot for
the trailer and I think what we've
learned now is that it is definitely not
a shot just made for the trail that was
a nice connection that the trailer gave
us that was a nice little morsel what
were some other things that you enjoyed
seeing it would appear that the Jedi and
the Sith the dark side yeah have crossed
into legend that's a great moment he
says the dark side the Jedi it's all
true to Rey and Finan and Star Wars has
you know 19 years after the Clone Wars
you forget everything that the Jedi were
legend there well this is 90 plus years
from now in Star Wars time
that's really the agent pass and the
fact that two characters in their early
20s are like is that stuff true and Hans
their guide on this journey that's
really cool and another thing I like to
how was this is clearly seems to be
Ray's story Dan
Ridley's character starts with her on
jakku she's a scavenger and pulling a
character out of obscurity onto a great
journey who did that before us well Luke
Skywalker another thing how yeah music
Oh music that's another thing that
evokes
the majesty of Star Wars and it gets you
it gives you goose flesh you don't hear
Luke's theme in the trailer you hear
Laius theme which to me kind of turns on
its head when we heard that they were
all coming back I think most people
assumed that Luke would be a major
player in the story
yeah and that han and Leia would be
minor players in the story and what this
trailer especially Han looks like he's
their guide he's their guide into the
world of myth and legend into the world
of the Jedi I think this is just as much
Han story passing the baton to to Rey
and Finn and these characters and Poe
Dameron who's getting apparently
tortured by kylo Ren and this darn stuff
for Star Wars and back to Dan's point if
not having too much revealed yet John
boyega fins and is he masquerading as a
stormtrooper is he actually a
stormtrooper it's cool to go in with
more questions than like okay look we
know this this is speculation time I
have a little bit of different of
opinion so yeah that's what I that's
what come on this is full on speculation
yes lay it out there I have a suspicion
because they say he said I was raised to
do one thing and now I have nothing to
fight for and we've seen him in disguise
as the stormtrooper I have a suspicion
that he was either recruited or joined
as a young man okay this new empire and
I believe there's a shot you know as we
said we saw Oscar Isaacs getting
tortured by kylo Ren yeah there's the
shot where the two characters meet each
other we see them he kind of bumps into
him he turns around that gives him a
look now I my theory yeah is that
through his participation he knows that
he's been captured and he's like what
are you doing here you're fighting for
again whatever this form of the
rebellion is yeah ken has a different
theory I think fent finn has left the
first-order he's joined the resistance
and I see Poe Dameron I think I see his
character is kind of a not fatherly
figure but older brother figured
maybe some of the resistance I think
it's more of hey you're here you're
fighting with us now and I'm proud of
you can I just say how refreshing it is
that we're looking at a Star Wars
trailer and we're speculating on the
good parts of the story absolutely what
might become of it instead of sitting
here going like how bad is this gonna be
yeah oh that character looks bizarre
yeah stupid we're not saying that also
this trailer I'm reminded by your shirt
can there was a lot more space battle
than we had seen previously and it looks
pretty badass JJ said practical is gonna
be the forefront of this movie of course
there's gonna be some CGI yeah
everything's gonna be rendered through a
computer at some point yeah but for the
most part it looks like we got models
exploded in space yeah you react to that
particularly that's always been my thing
with CGI is it should be a tool to do
something in a way that you couldn't do
it and it looks like he's using CG as a
way to take these familiar things we
know not make them cartoons but to put
the camera in places that are not
possible with models the shot of the
Millennium Falcon going into hyperspace
which by the way how cool is it to see
that star effect again but that tunnel
effect that was obviously a CG shot but
it didn't look that different from the
model shot that we saw an empire for
instance as you're talking one of the
things I'm thinking about there you know
we actually really haven't seen huh is a
space battle yet in these three they're
all fighting in in the atmosphere here
or above above that lake and yeah we
haven't actually seen them go to space
yet too much for long are they hiding
something you know what I mean if that
goes to what we said is we haven't seen
the whole picture yet right and got the
full context a couple other things that
we haven't talked about yet carrie
fisher's in the trailer they still
shacking up those two would appear so
yeah there's been speculation that maybe
they aren't and maybe they're banging
together everything but I love seeing
han and Leia together that's what I want
I want a happy ending for those days oh
and you know what else get me a little
geeked up I'm sold
I like that cross lightsaber now and
two-seam John boyega going up against
look like kylo Ren kylo Ren
without his helmet on if you look
closely and freeze it like I did several
times already kylo ren's how it is off
that speaks to maybe some ferocious kind
of realistic battle not some
choreographed lightsaber fight this crap
hitting fan Zach yeah this could be
something serious going on and there was
some tension there like John boyega
and looked like nervous as hell right
you know I get the sense that he's not a
Jedi he's someone learning more maybe
just has a lightsaber and let me figure
out how to do it and he's gonna learn
the hard way and hard way fast yeah
somebody's teaching him guys I'd love to
hear a favorite moment from this trailer
you know what I'm intrigued about and
1:45 in the trailer
Rey Daisy Ridley's character is bawling
her eyes out and again if you freeze it
it's over someone who's going
uh-oh who is going home man that was my
favorite moment
oh man who's going dan much like the
last trailer my favorite moment is a
little tiny moment the last trailer was
the practical shot of the story of the
TIE fighter blasting the stormtroopers
up in the air this one the shot of Han
and Chewie like this because I can just
see him go here we go again POW like
that is such an eye when you think of
Han and Chewie that is the pose you
think of them in on some alien planet
and deep trouble they're like how are we
gonna get out of this again so great to
see those two back together and they're
obviously they've gotten into they've
gotten into something else who knows
that they've gotten into I mean of
course he's gonna get into stuff he's a
scoundrel he's a scout scruffy-looking
nerf-herder
what was your favorite moment from the
Star Wars Force awakens trailer let us
know in the comments section below and
yeah are you as excited about this as we
are Ken Knapp Zach thanks for being here
Dan Merle you'll always be here I sleep
here yes and thanks for watching on how
ridiculous I watch the internet explode
I'm going Tintin I know look I love
posting house but I agree with Jermaine
in fact that how underrated Tintin was
will it be Tintin for the win win